and uh rich hill will make his mets
debut the 41 year old left-hander will
be pitching for his 11th different team
that's got him from tampa bay on friday
walking out to the mound for his mets
debut
become the oldest pitcher to start a
game for the met since bartolo colon and
the second oldest pitcher to start a
game for the mets
in his debut in the history of the
franchise george springer moved back
into the leadoff spot last night and he
opened up the scoring with a solo homer
in the third inning
his 139th career home run battling out
of the number one spot in the lineup
swinging a drive leftia this ball is
going to get down and it's a
fair ball down into the corner springer
gets a lead off double the move has paid
dividends immediately with springer
going to the top of the order
says he is comfortable at that lead off
position and it has shown since they
have put him out there and ended the
night for taiwan walker the runner goes
to third by neato and springer is tagged
out
springer running on a 3-0 pitch
and gets gunned down by neato for the
second out i don't know what george was
thinking there and they will take on
ross stripling trying to bounce back
from his shortest outing of his career
yeah that was just a third of an inning
last time out against the boston red sox
they touched him up for a couple of home
runs six earned runs and four hits
i went back to the drawing board said
you know what my fastball's okay
everything was fine they they just hit
me he is making his first career start
against the mets hoping to bounce back
brandon nemo
they were hitting 305 for the season
breaking ball just wasn't there his
change up wasn't very effective his
basketball command
i need him to do it and this is a good
start boy everything has been sharp
early on for stripling fastball command
got his curveball over change up and
cider have all worked
teach you a pitch
hit on the ground
as espina makes a nice play he was over
there in the shift two down and pete
alonzo will come to the plate looked
like he was ready to punch him out and
then fought differently
now he can do it he made up for that one
he gets the strikeout called strikeout
on the breaking ball ross stripping
retires a sign in order so two out and
here is santiago espinal getting the
start at third base today
on one to espinal and the curve ball hit
out to left field over toward the line a
long run for dom smith near the sidewalk
nice play
he caught it in fair territory right
before he crossed the line
tom has to cover a lot of ground to make
that play
davis hitting 349 with four homers 11
rbis
and that's drilled to left field by
davis and that'll get back to the wall
for an extra base hit so jd davis with a
one-out double and the mets have their
first base runner of the day well 3-1
hanging slider he's lucky that uh mr
davis did not lift this now here's vr
one for seven in this series
a little looper over short that'll fall
for a base hit davis read it well who
comes around third and he'll come in
with the first run of the game jonathan
vr an rbi single as good a base runner
as he is he makes some mistakes at time
just not picking the best spots to run
we've seen it on ground balls to the
infielders
but he will steal from time to time
swinging a miss there he goes the throw
to second is
in time
good throw from kirk good tag from
simeon a strike him out throw him out he
ends the second inning
marcus hits that first breaking ball and
bob smith on the run it's off his glove
and off the wall simeon is headed for
second
as dom smith got a piece of it but it
was just off the end of his glove and
it'll go for
a leadoff double here in the point but
for the third time in four innings now
the blue jays have led off and then
against rich hill with a double
another curveball lifted into the
outfield and dom smith will have an
easier play this time
and that's the second out
so hill keeps throwing the hooks
jays keep hitting them for routine fly
balls
would take that
drops down and he throws one that popped
up on the infield alonso comes in to
call it and that retires the side hill
who used to be a side armor earlier in
his career went back to the old days to
drop down against richie it's gonna take
kirk a while to go from first to second
five eight two sixty five stripping
squares pulls back
first and they pick off kern
how about that thomas needle with the
back pick guillerme going over to cover
and kirk was a dead duck
thrown out two on the bases today that
one's grounded weakly to the left side
jd cuts in front plenty of time to throw
out strippling five scoreless innings
now for rich hill in his mets debut
roddy guerrero to the plate
there's a drive into the alley and right
that's going to be up against the wall
on a hop springer is headed for third as
guerrilla comes through
and he drives into the opposite field
that frustration paying off here in his
next advantage he stayed on that pitch
and a bullet to the base of the wall and
right and that's going to be all for
rich hill yes it is i thought he aimed
that last curve ball
so five terrific innings for hill but he
gets in trouble in the sixth and now
lugo will come in to try to bail him out
with the mets leading one to nothing
all in all a successful mets debut for
41 year old rich hill who will leave
after five innings plus
bow has walked in flight out he has 63
rbis
0-2 pitch
breaking ball hit into center field
springer's in to score guerrero's being
waved around third here's the throw it's
cut off and beau delivers once again a
two-strike two-run rbi single to center
field
ground ball
third base they're going to come home
and
the ball is not caught by neato as
simeon comes in to score
the blue jays
get another run as tayasaka will pick up
an rbi
well pete hit that mammoth home run off
of uh for rocky in the first game
pete started the day with an eight-game
hitting streak he struck out and
grounded into a double play this
afternoon
and four to at second with one out three
and two defeat
[Applause]
and he cranks one to left deep head
toward the wall
pete alonso ties the game with a two-run
homer
alonso two berkey nothing it's three to
three what a nice advantage mcneal
trying to get the mets the lead
davis and vr will get set to run with
three and two and two out
[Music]
and mcneal drives one to right center
field that's gonna go up the gap and go
back to the wall the mets take the lead
davis is in vr right behind him jeff
mcneil with a two-run pigeon double and
the mets laid it five to three
that's a nice two-out rally right there
stays on that one and drives it into
right center as springer makes the catch
runners have to hold that ball was
sinking very quickly on springer
as alonzo went the other way with it and
george had to leave his feet and he
makes the catch for the second out of
the end go ahead run to the plate and
oscar hernandez and he could reach the
seats he did it twice yesterday
there's a line drive into center that's
going to cash in simeon from third
and it's a one run game
that's the difference in the blue jays
lineup compared to the mets there are
five guys at the top of the order that
can win a ball game for you he comes in
with the bases loaded in a one-run game
and
a big situation here
and bidgeo golf's one out to left but
dom is there
and the side retire one king sized out
for aaron luke
so it's left to beau buchette
3-2 coming to buchet
[Applause]
[Music]
he struck him out and the ball game is
over
edwin diaz three strikeouts in the ninth
to put down the powerful blue jays